This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。绝对真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方搜索数字“2%”。在《Look Back at It》播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是很大的一刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast上收听《Learn the Hard Way》，
or wherever you get your podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode. New listeners, old listeners. It is so amazing to have you. here. Thank you for tuning in for another episode of the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we break down some of the psychology behind the major events and situations and experiences of our 20s. It is so great to have you here. Thank you again for deciding to listen
或在你获取播客的任何地方。你好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活改变和过渡，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎收听新的一期节目。新听众，老听众。很高兴你们来到这里。感谢大家收听又一期的《20多岁的心理学》，这是一档剖析我们20多岁时的重大事件、情况和经历背后的心理学的播客。很高兴你能来到这里。再次感谢你决定收听，
wherever you are in the world. Today we're going to talk about one of my most requested topics. I get people asking me for this all the time and I think it is such a valuable episode to do. And I thought as many of our listeners in the US had Thanksgiving this weekend and we're approaching the holiday season, it's an important episode to do as we spend more time with our families and feel obligated to extend and to kind of engage with all of our family members and more from the knot that means our parents. So this is an episode for those who perhaps questioning the adult relationship or even the childhood relationship they had with their families, the good, the bad, the ugly. Most of us, we are lucky enough to have secure, healthy relationships with
无论你身在世界的哪个角落。今天我们要聊的是我最常被要求讨论的话题之一。经常有人问我这个问题，我认为这是一期非常有价值的节目。我想，既然我们在美国的许多听众这周末刚过完感恩节，而且我们正在接近假日季，当我们花更多时间陪伴家人，并觉得有义务去扩展和参与到我们所有的家庭成员以及不仅仅是父母的关系中时，这是一期很重要的节目。所以，这一期节目是献给那些可能在质疑自己与家人的成年关系，甚至是童年关系的人，无论是好是坏，还是丑陋的一面。大多数人，我们足够幸运，能够拥有安全、健康的与
our parents, but not every parental relationship is perfect. And that's what we're discussing today, the psychology of narcissistic and toxic parents. I will say before we get started, this episode is primarily going to cover emotional abuse. As we know, abuse can come in many forms and each is equally as harmful and painful as the next and deserves their own attention. But today, we're going to be talking about instances of emotional abuse and the emotional damage that can be inflicted by unhealthy parenting styles. And to add to this, I do just want to make a quick disclaimer before we begin and say that we are talking about some topics, situations, concepts that can and will be distressing for
父母的关系，但并非每一种父母与子女的关系都是完美的。这就是我们今天要讨论的内容，自恋型和有毒父母的心理学。在开始之前我想说，这期节目主要讨论情感虐待。正如我们所知，虐待可以有多种形式，每一种形式都与其他形式同样有害和痛苦，并且值得我们各自的关注。但今天，我们将讨论情感虐待的实例，以及由不健康的育儿方式所能带来的情感伤害。除此之外，在开始之前，我只想做一个简短的声明，那就是我们要讨论的一些话题、情况、概念，可能会而且将会给
some people. So if topics concerning toxic or even abusive family dynamics and parenting are something that you know can cause distress or trigger you, please just take a moment to reflect on whether this episode is something you need to hear today. I will also say this is a highly nuanced topic and one that would take many, many episodes to cover if we wanted to do a comprehensive sweep and a comprehensive deep dive, but sadly we don't have the time for that today. And as always, my intention with these episodes is to give you the most important parts of the research and the psychology behind these experiences and the realizations of our 20s.
有些人带来困扰。因此，如果涉及有毒甚至虐待性的家庭动态和育儿方式的话题是你已知会导致困扰或触动你的，请花一点时间思考一下，这一期节目是否是你今天需要听的内容。我还要说，这是一个高度细微差别的话题，如果我们想做一个全面而深入的探讨，需要很多很多的节目才能涵盖，但遗憾的是我们今天没有那么多时间。而且一如既往，我制作这些节目的初衷是为你提供关于这些经历背后的研究和心理学的最重要部分，以及我们20多岁的感悟。
and one of these, one that people ask me about quite a bit, is the adult relationship we begin to have with our parents as we gain independence and create our own lives during this decade. Often as we enter our 20s, we will see a slow or sometimes sudden shift in the dynamics we have with our parents and our caregivers and a recognition, perhaps, of some of the mistakes they may have made when raising us, mistakes that now impact us as adults. And not always just mistakes, but intentional kind of parenting styles that they may have adopted, that now we have the self-awareness to realize may have negatively impacted us. And this can be a really traumatic and confusing consequential realization as we grow into our own
其中之一，也是人们经常问我的一个问题，就是随着我们在这一十年中获得独立并创造自己的生活，我们开始与父母建立的成年关系。通常当我们进入20多岁时，我们会看到我们与父母和照顾者之间的动态关系发生缓慢的、有时甚至是突然的转变，或许会意识到他们在抚养我们时可能犯下的一些错误，这些错误现在正作为成年人影响着我们。而且不总是只有错误，还有他们可能采用的刻意的育儿方式，现在我们有了自我意识，意识到这些方式可能对我们产生了负面影响。当我们成长为属于自己的
versions of ourselves and think about what we may want for our futures, whether that's kids or deciding not to have kids or the many other options. our 20s are obviously a period of immense self-reflection. And it's often the time where we come to terms with this understanding that our parents, much like us, are people and they have their own beliefs, their own past, their own regrets, their own flaws. And it may also be a period in which we recognise that our parents may be accidentally, often not intentionally, have harmed us or caused certain habits or patterns of behaviour
不同版本的自己，并思考我们对未来的期望时，这可能是一个非常具创伤性、令人困惑且产生深远影响的觉醒，无论是想要孩子还是决定不生孩子，或者是其他诸多选择。我们的20多岁显然是一个进行巨大自我反思的时期。而且这通常是我们开始理解这一概念的时期：我们的父母和我们一样，也是人，他们有自己的信仰、自己的过去、自己的遗憾、自己的缺点。这也可能是一个我们意识到父母可能在无意中（通常并非故意）伤害了我们，或者根据他们在抚养我们时所做出的决定，在我们的内心
within us based on the decisions they made when they were raising us. And this recognition can bring about quite a bit of self-reflection internally as we address all of the things that come along with that, some of the blame, some of the shame. And I think one thing that's important to know and consider as we approach this period is the type of parents we may have had and their unique parenting styles, specifically what are the consequences and impact that these unique styles will and do have on our emotional. and mental well-being. I think it goes without saying that our parents, our caregivers, the ones that we have in childhood, they really greatly impact on our future experiences in
种下了某些习惯或行为模式的时期。这种认知可能会在内部引发相当多的自我反思，因为我们要处理随之而来的所有事情，包括一些指责、一些羞耻。我认为，当我们接近这个时期时，有一件重要的事情需要了解和考虑，那就是我们可能拥有的父母类型以及他们独特的育儿方式，特别是这些独特方式将对以及正在对我们的情感和心理健康产生什么后果和影响。我认为不言而喻的是，我们的父母、我们的照顾者，我们在童年时拥有的那些人，对我们未来的经历和心理状态有着巨大的影响。在我们婴儿期、童年期甚至青春期早期的绝大部分时间里，我们在各方面完全依赖他们，为了安全、食物、同情和自信，我们信任他们，我们真的很需要他们。不仅如此，我们出生的第一个家庭，也许是决定我们人生轨迹的最重要因素。无数的研究已经证实了这一点。在研究这期节目时，我发现了其中一个特别的研究。这是一项在美国进行的纵向研究，追踪了近800名学龄儿童，从出生一直到他们25岁。他们发现，你出生的家庭往往决定了你的人生道路和你的最终归宿。
mental state. For the majority of our infancy and our childhood and even our early teens, we are entirely dependent on them for everything, for safety, for food, for compassion and for confidence, we trust them and we really need them. And even beyond that, the first family that we're born into, it's perhaps like the single most important factor in determining our life trajectory. And heaps of studies have confirmed this. There was one in particular that I found while researching this episode. It's a longitudinal study conducted in the US and it followed nearly 800 school children from the time of birth until they were 25. And they found that the family you're born into often determines your life path and where you end up.
不仅是你的收入阶层、教育和机会，还包括你承载的创伤、你的信仰、你拥有的价值观，以及你长期健康的许多方面。如果你在听这期节目时，曾经或正在经历一个有毒的、自恋的或虐待性的照顾环境或童年，我想说这并不是世界末日，虽然我们的照顾者所采取的育儿方法和我们的童年环境确实至关重要，
not just, you know, your income bracket and your education and opportunities, but also the trauma you hold, the beliefs, the values you have, and many aspects of your long-term health. If you're listening to this having had or having experienced a toxic, narcissistic or abusive caregiving environment or childhood, I do want to say it's not all doom and gloom, whilst, you know, a parenting approach adopted by our caregivers and our childhood environment is really crucial.
但它受到许多其他重要决定因素的缓解。而且一如既往，我们希望在这些节目中采取以优势为基础的方法。我们希望看到未来，看到曙光，看到我们从经历中成长的机遇，而不仅仅是我们20多岁时的经历。因此，在本集结束时，肯定会有一场讨论，关于我们可以做些什么来尝试去应对我们与成年父母的成年关系，以及当我们还是孩子时，如何克服可能存在的虐待性、有毒或自恋的照顾环境。因此，让我们深入探讨有毒的育儿方式或有毒的
It is mitigated by many other important determinants. And as always, we want to take a strength-based approach during these episodes. We want to see the future, see the light, see the opportunities that we have to grow from our experiences, not just the ones we have in our 20s. So there is definitely going to be a discussion at the end of this episode about what we can do to try and, you know, to navigate our adult relationship with our adult. parents and how do we overcome perhaps an abusive or toxic or narcissistic caregiving environment when we were children. So let's dive into, you know, what a toxic parenting style or a toxic
照顾环境可能是什么样的，它的一些影响是什么，以及我们如何才能前进。让我们直接切入正题。究竟什么是自恋的育儿方式，它与健康、安全的育儿方式以及健康、安全的童年环境、健康的成长环境有何不同。如果你听过关于克服童年创伤的那期节目，我们在那期节目中更深入地探讨了这个话题，但为了给那些可能没有时间听那一期节目的听众提供一个概述，本质上，一个健康的童年环境是一个没有创伤的环境，一个不一定没有挣扎，但充满支持的环境，在这个环境中，我们觉得周围的人，特别是我们的父母，正在提供我们的需求，以及我们本质上
caregiving environment might look like in some of the impacts, but also how we can move forward. So let's get straight into it. What exactly is toxic parenting as opposed to healthy, secure parenting and a healthy, secure childhood environment, a healthy secure upbringing. If you listen to the episode on overcoming childhood trauma, we delve much deeper into this topic in that episode, but to give those an overview who may have not had the time to listen to that, essentially a healthy childhood environment is one that is free of trauma, one that is free of not necessarily struggle, but one that is supportive in which we feel like the people, who surround us, particularly our parents, are providing our needs and the needs that we essentially
需要得到满足的需求。它不一定是没有创伤的。它是一个充满支持的环境，而有毒的童年环境可能是你的需求在情感、身体、社会、精神上都没有得到满足的环境。它通常由某种程度的创伤所定义。我想，当我们想到创伤时，我们通常会想到一些非常重大的事件，比如战争、巨大的事故、重大的伤害、疾病或死亡。这并不一定总是如此。当我们更多地谈论有毒的育儿方式时，我们会发现，即使是不稳定和消极的成长环境以及父母环境，也足以产生创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）和长期创伤。因此，本质上，有毒的育儿方式是一种糟糕的育儿方式，
need met. It's not necessarily one that is free of trauma. It's one that is an environment of support, whereas a toxic childhood environment might be one in which your needs aren't met emotionally, physically, socially, mentally. And it's often defined by some level of trauma. And I think when we think about trauma, we often think about really major events like a war or a massive accident or a massive, you know, injury or illness or a death. That's not always necessarily the case. When we talk more about toxic parenting, we'll see that even just an unstable and negative upbringing and parental environment is enough to create PTSD and long-term trauma. So essentially, toxic parenting, it's poor parenting,
在这种方式下，父母与孩子之间的关系是不健康的，它不利于合作、支持和无条件的爱，我认为这是每个孩子都非常、非常需要的东西。而且这并不总是父母的错，你知道的，我们稍后会对此进行更多讨论。有时这是由于代际创伤、代际学习以及文化和社会
in which the relationship that a parent and child has is not healthy, it's not conducive to collaboration and to support and to unconditional love, which is, I think, something every child really, really needs. And it's not always the parents' fault, you know, like we'll talk about this a lot more later. Sometimes it's because of generational trauma and generational learnings and cultural and societal
期望所致。但本质上，有毒的育儿方式会导致孩子无法信任父母。孩子不敢去找父母，可能是因为父母忽视了他们的需求，尤其是他们的情感需求，甚至可能存在虐待的实例，不仅是身体上的，还有其他各种虐待。拥有有毒父母和与父母有毒关系的成年人，通常在他们年长之前、在他们20多岁之前，甚至无法认识到这些行为本质上是错误的、失策的，有时甚至是残酷的。而且他们最终往往会带有心理和行为上的问题或损害，尽管他们表面上看起来是一个完美、稳重、正常运转的人，但在内心和潜意识里，情况并非总是如此。
expectations. But essentially toxic parenting results in an inability for a child to trust their parent. For a child to go to their parent might be because that parent is neglecting their needs, especially their emotional needs, and there might even be instances of abuse, not just physical, but every other kind. Adults who have toxic parents in a toxic relationship with their parents, normally they're not even able to recognize that those behaviours were inherently wrong or miscalculated or even sometimes cruel until they're older until they're in their 20s. And often they'll end up with psychological and behavioral issues or damage that although they may seem like this well, perfect, put together functioning person internally and unconsciously, that's not always the case. and that's why this can bring along with it a cycle of negative thinking of being over-critical to ourselves of feeling guilt and shame.
这就是为什么这会带来一连串的负面思维循环，对自己过于苛刻，产生内疚和羞耻感。关于有毒尤其是自恋式育儿的许多研究都来自20世纪，也就是上个世纪。显然，当我们想到社交媒体和互联网的出现时，事情已经取得了长足的进步，比如孩子们现在与父母的互动动态已经完全改变了。孩子们成熟得快得多。我总是看到这些TikTok视频，人们说，哦，你知道，当我读初中或者13岁的时候，我长这样，而现在的孩子长这样。
A lot of the research done on toxic and particularly narcissistic parenting came from the 1900s, so last century. And obviously things have come a long way when we think about the emergence of social media and the internet, like the dynamics that children have with their parents now are completely changed. children are growing up so much quicker. Like I always see these TikToks of people being like, oh, you know, when I was in middle school or when I was 13, like, this is what I look like versus what children these days look like.
这显然是一个巨大的对比。尽管有大量研究探讨社交媒体如何扰乱儿童与父母之间的动态关系，使其成熟得更快，但这仍然是我们没有太多长期研究和长期文献的领域。但让我们深入探讨这些早期的研究。我们知道，根据经验，不同的父母有不同的育儿方式和满足孩子需求的方式，有时则是未能满足孩子的需求。育儿方式本质上是一种心理构念，它概述了特定的行为和特征，
And it's obviously a massive comparison. And although there is heaps of research into how social media is kind of disrupting the dynamic that children and parents have is making children kind of mature faster, it's still something that we don't have many like long-term studies and long-term research into. But let's dive into this early research. We know that anecdotally, different parents have different ways of parenting and providing for their children's needs, sometimes not providing for their children's needs. A parenting style is essentially, it's a psychological construct that outlines the specific behaviors and characteristics
这些行为和特征定义了一个人和父母在抚养孩子时认为合适或必要的东西。这些做法部分由文化、他们生活的环境、社会期望，当然还有代际学习，有时甚至是代际创伤所形成。如果说有一位研究人员、
that define what a person and what a parent deems as appropriate. or necessary when raising a child. And these practices are formed in part by culture, by the environment that they live in, societal expectations, and of course generational learning, and at times generational trauma. If there is one researcher,
有一位心理学家在本集中是必须要记住名字的，那就是戴安娜·鲍姆林德（Diana Baumrind），她基本上是家庭育儿心理学的创始人。我不确定这算不算一个学科，但基本上就是研究父母和人们为什么以不同方式抚养孩子背后的心理学的研究。她观察了不同代际、不同环境和不同文化中的儿童。她发现了她认为是塑造成功育儿的四个基本要素，它们是处理孩子的几种矛盾方式。这就是响应性
one psychologist whose name it is important to remember from this episode, it's Diana Bormoran, she was basically like the family, founder of parental psychology. I'm not sure if that's a discipline, but basically research into the psychology behind why parents and why people raise their children differently. And she observed children across many different kind of generations and environments and cultures. And she found what she considers to be the four basic elements that help shape successful parenting and they're kind of these contradictory ways of treating a child. There's responsiveness
与无响应性，以及要求性与非要求性，抱歉，是要求性与非要求性。这两种光谱和四个特征决定了你我可能曾拥有的父母类型。父母的响应性，本质上是指父母愿意以支持和接受的方式回应孩子需求的程度，这种方式有利于接受孩子的意见，有利于长期的情感支持，以及在建立在信任和尊重基础上的健康、可持续关系中实现长期成长。父母的要求性，指的是父母对孩子制定的规则、实施的纪律程度、他们的严厉程度、
versus unresponsiveness and demanding versus undemanding, sorry, demanding versus undemanding. And these kind of two spectrums and four characteristics determine the type of parent that you and I may have had. Parental responsiveness, essentially that refers to the degree to which a parent is willing to respond to their child. needs in a supportive and accepting manner in a way that is conducive to input from their child and it's conducive to long-term emotional support and long-term growth in a healthy, sustainable relationship built on trust and on respect. Parenthoodle demandingness refers to the rules which are parent places on their child, the amount of discipline they enact, how strict they are,
他们对孩子的期望，以及如果打破这些规则随之而来的后果。由此我们可以识别出四种不同的育儿方式，我希望你们听清楚这四种方式。这有四种，看看这里的任何特征是否让你觉得眼熟。看看你是否能在这些资料中认出你的父母。我不确定这是否是最健康的练习，但看看你的父母、照顾者和家庭在这个光谱上处于什么位置，这是一个有趣的做法，对吧？这四种风格是：权威型、专制型、忽视型和放任型/纵容型。
what they expect of their child, and the repercussions. that follow these rules if they're broken. So from this we can identify four different styles of parenting and I want you to listen to these. So there's four and see if any of the traits here are recognisable. See if you can identify your parents in these kind of profiles. I'm not sure if this is like the healthiest exercise but it's an interesting one right to see where your parents and where your caregivers and where your family might sit on the spectrum. So the four styles are authoritative and authoritarian. Yes, they're different. Authoritative, authoritarian, neglectful, and indulgent slash permissive.
所以第一种，专制型。这些父母要求很高，但缺乏响应性。大量、大量的研究已经针对这些父母的孩子展开，探讨他们中有多少人最终成为罪犯，当然并不是所有人都会变成这样，而且这显然是由其他环境和其他生活方式因素共同导致的，但通常这些孩子们可能会变成无法把自己视为被爱的人，无法在社会中看到自己的映象或受到尊重的人。这些父母坚信要为孩子制定规则去遵守，但却不太愿意倾听孩子的心声，把孩子视为独立的人，或者把他们的观点纳入考量。
So the first one, authoritarian. These parents are quite demanding, but they're not responsive. And a lot, a lot of research has been done into the children of these parents and how a lot of them end up becoming criminal offenders, obviously not all of them. become and you know it's it's obviously contributed by other circumstances and by other lifestyle factors but often these children can turn into people that aren't able to see themselves as being loved and unable to see themselves reflected or respected in society these parents are big believers in setting rules for their children to follow but not so much interested in listening to their children, seeing their children as independent people or taking their view into consideration.
他们通常认为小孩子“只应被看到，不应被听到”。他们不愿为自己的行为道歉，也不愿意倾听孩子。通常，你知道的，这就是那个老生常谈的解释：“因为我这么说了”，来作为他们决定的理由。我们可以看出，这并没有留下多少建设性的、双向交流的关系空间。其结果是，这些孩子们长大后不仅相当焦虑，而且往往相当叛逆，或者他们可能会发现很难为自己建立界限，因为父母总是为他们包办一切。他们在一个非常严格的环境中长大。他们习惯于服从
They often believe that children are best to be seen and not heard. They're not willing to apologize for their actions or listen to their children. Often, you know, it's that whole age old, like, because I said so explanation for their decisions. And we can kind of see that that doesn't leave much room for a constructive, two-sided relationship. And the result is these children often grow up to not only be quite anxious, but often quite rebellious, or they might find it difficult to establish boundaries for themselves, because their parents have always done it for them. They've grown up in this really strict environment. They're used to obeying
而不是领导。这也可能导致这些孩子们长大后变得相当——我不喜欢“缺乏纪律”这个词，而是——相当叛逆。这不一定是件坏事，对吧？也许他们长大后变得非常有创意，或者非常有独立思考能力，因为他们在抗拒父母育儿环境、成长经历的限制性。这就是专制型。现在我们来谈谈权威型。这些父母有规则，对孩子的行为有后果，但他们也会把孩子的意见考虑在内。因此，他们肯定孩子的感受，但同时也明确表示，你知道的，我们在掌权。我们是成年人。我们是父母，
rather than leading. It can also result in these children growing up to be quite, I don't like the word, undisciplined, but, like, rebellious. That's not necessarily a bad thing, right? Like maybe they grew up to be really creative or to be really free thinking because they're pushing back against the restrictiveness of their parental environment of their upbringing. So that was authoritarian. Now let's talk about authoritative. These parents have rules and they have consequences for the actions of their children, but they also take their children's opinion into account. So they validate their children's feelings, but making it clear, you know, that we're in charge. We are the adult. We are the parent. that's kind of the lay of the land. So if you're listening to this and thinking, oh my God, that sounds like my parents, that's probably the case.
这就是现状。所以如果你听到这里并心想，哦天哪，这听起来就像我的父母，那可能确实如此。这是最突出的育儿方式。而且它也得到了大量专家和大量研究的支持，认为它是最有利于身心健康和最有效的育儿方式。因为这些父母付出了大量的心血来与孩子建立和维持积极的关系，而不是仅仅站在他们掌权而孩子低人一等的立场上。这其中没有那种奇怪的、异样的等级制度，即孩子永远低他们一等，并且应该全盘接受他们施加的一切，对吧？
It is the most prominent parenting style. And it's also backed by heaps of experts and heaps of research that it's the most developmentally healthy and effective parenting style. Because these parents, they put a lot of effort into creating and maintaining a positive relationship with their child, not just from this like this position of them being in charge and the child being inferior. Like there isn't this weird, like weird strange hierarchy of the child will always be below them and should take whatever they hand down to them, right?
他们想要沟通，想要诚实，想要听取孩子的意见。正如我所说，这是最健康、最有效的育儿方式，因为孩子们既获得了他们所需的结构和安全感，也获得了独立和对他们情感需求的尊重。接下来我们是放任型。所以放任型的父母，他们超级有爱，对吧？他们超级慈爱，超级包容，但他们对孩子没有太多要求。他们非常宽容。他们真的不想干涉。他们真的不想给孩子设定界限或规则。这完全没问题，只要你没有伤害你的孩子。但在某些方面，这确实在长期内伤害了他们。因为这些父母不想，你知道的，
They want communication, they want honesty and they want their children's input. Like I said, the most healthy and effective parenting style because children are both given the structure and safety that they need, but also the independence and respect of their emotional needs. Next up we have permissive. So permissive parents, they're super loving, right? They're super affectionate, super accepting, but they don't make many demands of their children. They are very lenient. They don't really want to interfere. They don't really want to give their children boundaries or rules. That's totally fine, as long as you're not harming your child. But there are some ways in which this does hurt them in the long term. Because these parents don't want to, you know,
他们倾向于避免与孩子发生冲突。他们不倾向于建立常规的规则和常规的界限。他们往往会导致这样的孩子，你知道的，拥有过多的自由。他们缺乏通常所需的纪律。他们可能在学业上挣扎，并且难以理解界限。但它也是一种健康的育儿方式，因为他们鼓励孩子谈论问题。他们不让孩子，你知道的，乞求爱、乞求夸奖或乞求关爱。所以，这是第三种类型。最后一种是我们将在本集剩余时间里重点关注的类型。
they tend to avoid conflict with their children. They don't tend to set up routine rules and routine boundaries. They often result in children who, you know, have a bit too much freedom. They're without discipline that is often needed. They might struggle academically and struggle to understand boundaries. But it's also a healthy parenting style in the way that they encourage their kids to talk about issues. They don't make their children, you know, beg for love or beg for compliments or beg for affection. So, That's the third type. And the final is the one that we're going to focus on for the remainder of this episode.
这是一种有毒的育儿方式。它可能是最糟糕的一种。它被称为“不参与型”，这是最后一种育儿方式，也许是最危险的。并且与我们稍后将讨论的自恋型育儿联系最紧密。不参与型的父母，几乎不作任何要求。但他们也不付出任何回报。所以不参与型的父母，他们期望，你知道的，
It is the toxic parenting style. It is perhaps the worst. And it's called uninvolved. And this is the final parenting style, perhaps the most dangerous. And the most linked to narcissistic parenting, which we're going to talk about a little bit later. Uninvolved parents, they demand almost nothing. But they give nothing in return. So uninvolved parents, they expect, you know, they're,
孩子们自己抚养自己，拥有终极的、通常达到忽视程度的独立性。他们不设定期望。他们不设定界限或后果。他们也可能花很多时间不在家。他们甚至可能不把精力放在孩子的基本需求上。有时这并不是他们的错。当我们谈论这些不同的育儿方式时，我们确实需要考虑那些我们一无所知的环境和外部因素。但这只是心理学家、治疗师或社区中的人在审视一个不参与型父母时可能会看到的典型特征。它基本上已经处于忽视的边缘。当然，他们可能还有另一个问题在起作用，对吧？你知道的，
kids to raise themselves to have like ultimate often neglectful, neglectful level of independence. They don't set expectations. They don't set boundaries or consequences. They may also spend a lot of time away from home. They might not even put energy into their children's basic needs. Sometimes this isn't their fault. Like we really need to be considerate when we talk about these different parenting styles of the circumstances and external factors that we don't really know anything about. But this is just a typical profile of what a psychologist or a therapist or someone in the community might see if they were looking at an uninvolved parent. It basically kind of verges on the territory of neglect. And of course they might have another issue at play, right? You know,
某种干扰了他们照顾孩子能力的因素。也许他们有成瘾问题、心理健康问题、缺乏教育、严重的经济压力，他们需要在照顾孩子之前先解决这些问题。但这并不是一个充满爱的环境。孩子感觉不到被关爱。他们觉得父母没有在他们身上投入。你知道的，他们可能不会问孩子关于学校、体育比赛或他们过得怎么样的事情。我们可以看到这是多么具有破坏性和有害。
something that interferes with their ability to look after their child. Maybe they have an issue with addiction or mental health problems, a lack of education, severe financial stress, that they need to kind of manage first before they can take care of their children. But it's not a very loving environment. The child doesn't feel cared for. They don't feel like their parents invest in them. You know, they might not ask their kids about school or sporting games or how their days were. And we can see how detrimental and harmful this is going to be.
没有一个关心我们的人会营造出一个非常缺乏爱的环境，在这里作为孩子，我们感觉不到自己在情感上得到了支持，我们无法信任，我们感觉不到有人关心我们，我不知道，当我研究这个的时候，我脑子里想的全部都是，我不知道，就像一个无助的小孩子，只想要有人问问他们今天过得怎么样，或者帮他们做作业，这让我心碎，你知道，非常心碎，但是这种情况确实会发生。这确实会发生，正如我们所说，大多数父母都会落入那四种类别之一。所以如果那是你的经历，我真的很抱歉，如果那是你的经历，但我们接下来会讨论更多这其实并不是人生的终点。这并不是我们生活的终结。我们知道这四种风格并不是穷尽的。
not having someone who cares about us can create a really unloving environment where we don't feel as children like we are emotionally supported we aren't able to trust we don't feel like we have someone who cares about us like I don't know when I was researching this all I could think about was like I don't know like a tiny helpless child just wanting someone to ask them how their day was or help them with their homework makes my heartache you know so much but It does happen. It does happen, as we said, like most parents will fall into that kind of one of those four categories. So if that was you, I'm really sorry, if that was your experience, but we'll talk about more how that's, you know, not really the end of the line. That's not really the end of our lives. We know that these four styles are not exhaustive.
你知道的，还有许多其他不同的风格。有慢速育儿、积极育儿、我不知道，温和育儿。这些天超级受欢迎。我在大学里学到的另一个可爱的育儿方式叫做“海豚育儿法”。我觉得这超级甜蜜。它基本上被描述为一种育儿方式，包括几乎像孩子的朋友一样，超级好玩、善于社交且注重独立性。我脑海里总是浮现这样的画面：海豚妈妈和海豚爸爸或者说父母在开阔的水域里，然后它们的小海豚宝宝在它们身边闲逛，四处游荡，
You know, there are so many other different styles. There's slow parenting, positive parenting, I don't know, gentle parenting. That's super popular these days. another cute one that I learned when I was at uni was called dolphin parenting. I think this is like it's so sweet. It's basically described as a type of parenting that involves being almost like a friend to one's child, super playful and social and focused on independence. Like I always get like the visual of like the dolphin like mom and dad or like parent out in the open waters and like their little baby dolphin like hanging out beside them going off
做它们自己的事情，但总是会回来，对吧？保持顽皮，充满活力。我不知道。挺可爱的。但还有其他类型的育儿方式，可不是海豚育儿法，它们就没那么可爱了。然后我想在本集的剩余时间里重点关注这一点。所以有一种特定的父母引起了极大的关注，那就是自恋的父母。我认为这非常有趣，但同时也可能相当令人不安。
doing their own thing but always coming back, right? being playful, being like, jubilant. I don't know. It's quite cute. But there are other types, not dolphin parenting, that aren't so cute. And then I want to focus on for the rest of this episode. So one particular parent that has gotten a lot of attention is the narcissistic parent. I think this is so interesting, but also can be quite disturbing.
所以很显然，我们都知道自恋的人在社会上是存在的。事实上，有研究甚至表明，大约每200人中就有1人患有自恋症。是的，这是一种障碍。这不是人们可以控制的，也不是他们自愿选择成为的，尽管如此，自恋者的行为仍然可以具有难以置信的破坏性。那么当这些人有了孩子会发生什么？以及我们如何识别我们的父母是否可能是自恋的父母，而不仅仅是一个自恋的人，并允许那些口头态度渗透到他们对待
So obviously, we all know that narcissistic people, they exist in society. In fact, there are studies that even suggest like one in 200 people have narcissism. And yeah, it's a disorder. It's not something that people can control or that they willingly choose to be, but the behaviors of a narcissist nonetheless can be incredibly harmful. So what happens when these people have children? And how do we identify if our parent might be a narcissistic parent, not just a narcissistic person, but allow those kind of oral attitudes bleed into how they treat
孩子的方式中去。在我们深入探讨之前，先对自恋做一个简短的定义。如果你感兴趣，我们有一集关于这个主题的节目，即自恋的心理学，但如果你需要复习一下，基本上自恋者是一个对自我有过度兴趣或崇拜并且无法看到他人观点的人。每个人显然都有点自恋。我们有美好的一天，也有糟糕的一天。这是作为人类的一部分，就像所有的特征一样。通常作为青少年，我们在发育过程中甚至会经历这样一个时期，
their children. Let's give a brief definition of narcissism before we get into it. We have an episode on this, on the psychology of narcissism if you're interested, but if you do need a refresher, basically a narcissist is a person who has an excessive interest or admiration of themselves and isn't able to see the point of view of others. everyone is obviously a little bit narcissistic. We have good days, we have bad days. It's part of being a human like all traits are. And often as adolescents, we even go through a period developmentally
我们有一种夸大的自我意识。然而，当自恋开始干扰一个人的功能发挥，以及他们在家里、工作场所、学校的功能发挥时，这就成了问题。这时它就偏离了单纯的特征范畴，进入了人格障碍的领域。因此，这些人对自己的重要性有着不合理的高估，但与此同时，
where we have an exaggerated sense of self. When narcissism begins to interfere with how a person functions though and how they function at home, at work, at school, that's when it's problematic. And that's when it veers into the realm of a personality disorder, rather than just a trait. So these people, they have an unreasonably high sense of their own self-importance, but in kind of conjunction with that and alongside that,
他们的同理心水平也很低，当他们觉得别人不尊重他们或不崇拜他们时，往往会大发雷霆。而且他们可能会，你知道的，在没有获得特殊优待、在别人没有满足他们的需求时感到失望。他们发现自己的人际关系，包括与孩子的关系（如果他们有孩子的话），非常令人不满足，因为他们对对方索取太多。
they also have really low levels of empathy and can often lash out when they feel that people aren't respecting them or don't admire them. And they might be, you know, disappointed when they're not given special favours, when people don't meet their needs. And they find their relationships, including with their children, if they have them, to be really unfulfilling because they want so much from the other person.
所以让我们回答之前提出的那个问题。当这些人成为父母时会发生什么？美国佐治亚大学的两位研究人员对此进行了相当长时间的关注。他们本质上是自恋领域的专家。他们发现的是，当自恋者有了孩子时，通常他们会完全失去对孩子的兴趣，转而寻找其他获取认同感的来源，这往往导致了我们刚刚讨论的那种育儿方式，即不参与型的父母，但达到了更高的程度。
So let's answer that question we had before. What happens when these people become parents? So there was two researchers out of the University of Georgia in the US who have focused on this for quite some time. They're essentially experts in narcissism. And what they found is that when narcissists have children, often they lose interest in their children entirely and look for other sources of validation, often leading to that parenting style we kind of just discussed like the uninvolved parent, but to an added degree.
另一些人则倾向于将孩子视为自己的倒影。他们变得过度参与和控制。他们将孩子视为自我提升的机会，而不仅仅是作为一个孩子，作为一个正在成长的有血有肉的人。根据他们谋求私利的倾向，他们往往高度重视孩子能如何为他们的地位、外表以及人们如何看待他们做出贡献，而不是把最重要的事情放在孩子本身的状况上，他们精神状态如何，
Others tend to view their children as a reflection of themselves. They become hyper-involved and controlling. They see their children as an opportunity for self-advancement rather than just as a child, as someone who was a human who was growing. And as per their self-seeking tendencies, they often place a lot of value on how a child can contribute to their status and their appearance and how people see them, rather than the most important thing being how that child is, how they are mentally,
他们过得怎么样。我知道这听起来太基础了，但一个孩子应该被允许成为一个孩子，而不应该背负着父母的期望，这种期望压下来并造成有毒的环境。他们对孩子有着极高的期望。那些没有在感到无聊时完全抛弃孩子的自恋父母，会推动他们的孩子在各方面都表现优异。他们相信自己的孩子是特别的，配得上特殊的机遇和特权，但他们拒绝容忍自己孩子哪怕一点点不完美的表现。
how they're going. I know it sounds so basic, but like a child should be allowed to be a child without the expectations of a parent kind of like veering down on them and creating a toxic environment. They have really high expectations of their children. Those of the narcissistic parents who don't, you know, completely abandon them when they get kind of bored. And they push their kids to excel in everything. They believe that their children are special and deserving of special opportunities and privileges, but they refuse to tolerate anything less than perfection from their own child.
所以这有时会导致所谓的自恋型父母虐待，这涉及那些极度需要赞赏或关注的父母，而代价却是以巨大牺牲孩子的发展和福祉为代价的。他们变得痴迷，对孩子能为他们做什么、孩子的成功和荣誉以及与他们有关的一切、他们的外表将如何反映在他们自己身上感到痴迷。这可能是潜意识里发生的。自恋虐待的目标并不总是被煽动它的那个人有意识地知道。但本质上，当我们看到一个以这种方式行事的自恋型父母时，基于他们这种失调的人格，最终的目标、他们心中最核心的东西，就是掌控一切，成为房间里最重要的人，
So this sometimes leads into what is called narcissistic parental abuse, and this involves parents who excessively need admiration or attention at an enormous cost to their child's development and well-being. They become obsessed, obsessed with what their child can do for them, how their child's, you know, successes and accolades and everything else to do with them, their looks will reflect on them. And it may be done subconsciously. The goal of narcissistic abuse isn't always known consciously to the person who is instigating it. But essentially, when we see a narcissistic parent who is acting in this way, the ultimate kind of goal, the ultimate thing that they have in mind, based on this kind of disordered personality they have, is to be in control and is to be the most important person in the room.
所以他们愿意做任何事来让孩子顺从他们认为生活应该发展的方向。他们将自己这个照顾者置于关系的中心，而不是孩子，我想我们都同意在童年时期中心应该是孩子。自恋型父母虐待的受害者，如果你经历过这一切，如果你曾有一个对你的成功如此痴迷、对你能为他们做什么如此痴迷的父母，但同时又如此以自我为中心、如此专注于别人对你的看法、对他们的看法以及对你们家庭的看法，或者也许他们根本不在乎你，只顾自己的事业或自己的愿景和外表。通常发生的事情是，遭受过这些折磨的人会感到羞耻。他们感到不重要。他们感到微不足道。有时他们会对他们所遭受的虐待行为（通常是情感虐待行为）感到自责，因为自恋者非常擅长扭曲叙事，
so they're willing to do anything to make their child comply with how they think their lives should go. And they kind of place themselves as the caregiver at the center of the relationship that rather than the child, and I think we can all agree that it should be the child in childhood. The victims of narcissistic parental abuse, if you've been through this, if you've had a parent who is so obsessed with your success is so obsessed with what you can do for them, but also so focused on themselves, so focused in what other people think of you and think of
这样他们就永远不是恶棍，他们总是英雄般的存在，他们总是那个拥有所有惊人品质并超越一切的如同神一般的人。这是你的错。都是因为你没能给他们留下深刻印象，没能达到他们的标准，所以才发生了这一切。而且，你知道的，自恋型父母的虐待有不同的类型。它可以是身体上的、心理上的、情感上的，你知道的，包括言语侮辱或煤气灯操纵（精神控制）、严厉的批评、心理游戏、被动攻击、冷暴力，诸如此类，列举不完。
them and think of your family, or perhaps they just don't care about you at all in favor of their own careers or in favor of their own kind of vision and external appearance. Typically what happens is people who've suffered through this, they feel ashamed. They feel unimportant. They feel insignificant. And sometimes they feel responsible for the abusive behavior that they kind of were subjected to, often emotionally abusive behavior, because narcissists are really great at twisting a narrative, so that they are never the villain, they are always kind of the hero, they are always the godlike person who has all these amazing qualities and who rises above. It was your fault. You're the reason this happened because you failed to impress them and meet their standards. and, you know, there are different types of narcissistic parental abuse. It can be physical, psychological, emotional, you know, including things like verbal insults or gaslighting, harsh criticisms, mind games, like passive aggressiveness, silent treatment, like the list goes on and on and on.
他们，只想着自己的家庭，或者他们根本不在乎你，只顾着自己的事业或者他们自己的某种愿景和外在表现。通常情况下，经历过这种折磨的人会感到羞耻。他们会觉得自己不重要，觉得自己微不足道。有时他们甚至会觉得自己应该为自己所遭受的虐待行为负责，通常是情感上的虐待，因为自恋者非常擅长扭曲事实，让他们自己永远不是坏人，而是那种英雄般的人物，他们永远是那种拥有各种惊人品质、高高在上的神一般的人物。错的是你。事情变成这样都是你的原因，因为你没有能打动他们，没有达到他们的标准。而且，你知道的，自恋型父母的虐待有不同的类型。它可能是身体上的、心理上的、情感上的，你知道的，包括言语侮辱、精神控制（气灯效应）、严厉的批评、心理游戏，比如消极抵抗、冷暴力，这样的例子简直举不胜举。
And, you know, sometimes I think there is this weird comparison in psychology and in therapy that, like, there is this kind of spectrum of abuse. and at one end is like the things we typically really cringe over it and make us really, you know, distressed and feel really uncomfortable, which is sexual and physical abuse. And then, you know, there's things down the other end, like silent treatment and passive aggressiveness might not seem as detrimental, but oh my goodness, and that is entirely false. They absolutely are because they teach a child that they are alone, that they cannot trust their parents, they are not valued, that they are not cared for, that they, that they are not cared for, that they're invisible and many behaviors that are sometimes instituted by narcissistic parents are
而且，你知道，有时我认为在心理学和治疗中存在一种奇怪的比较，就是说，存在一种所谓的虐待光谱。光谱的一端是我们通常真正感到反感、让我们真正、你知道，感到痛苦和极度不适的事情，也就是性和身体虐待。然后，你知道，另一端还有一些事情，比如冷暴力和被动攻击，可能看起来没有那么大危害，但天哪，这完全是错误的。它们绝对具有危害性，因为它们向孩子灌输一种观念：他们是孤独的，他们不能信任父母，他们是不被重视的，他们是不被关心的，他们是不被关心的，他们是隐形的，而自恋型父母有时采取的许多行为被
overlooked by teachers in general society because they look good. Narcissists are so great at making the external appearance of their parenting style look good. You know, it might seem beneficial to be encouraging your child to achieve specific goals and to groom your child to be seen as like the golden pupil and the golden child. but it might also be narcissistic parental abuse. I do just want to say, not all people who are narcissists go and to treat their children as we have described. And it's really rare that this would be, or that you have experienced this type of parent, but it doesn't mean it doesn't happen.
教师和一般社会所忽视，因为它们看起来很好。自恋者非常擅长把他们育儿方式的外部形象装扮得很好。你知道，鼓励孩子实现特定目标，把孩子培养成所谓的模范生和金牌儿童，这看起来可能是有益的。但这也有可能是自恋型的父母虐待。我只是想说，并非所有自恋的人都会像我们所描述的那样对待他们的孩子。这种情况非常罕见，或者说你经历过这种类型的父母也很罕见，但这并不意味着它不会发生。
And it doesn't mean that when it does, it's quite harmful. Just because perhaps your parent might fit some of these descriptions, it doesn't mean that they were abusive narcissistic parents. I think it's important to also consider a lot of other things and to really seek professional help and the professional opinion if you are suddenly identifying attributes of your parents in these kind of descriptions. But once again, like this parental style, it's so disruptive, it's so dysfunctional
并且这并不意味着当它发生时，它的危害其实很大。仅仅因为你的父母可能符合其中的某些描述，并不意味着他们就是虐待型的自恋父母。我认为同样重要的是要考虑许多其他事情，如果你突然在这些描述中发现了自己父母的特质，一定要寻求专业帮助和专业的意见。但再说一次，这种育儿方式是如此具有破坏性，如此功能失调，
and it can be really, really harmful in the long term. I just want to stress as well, like, if this is something that you can relate to, it's not some kind of, like, death sentence, like, a sign of your certificate, like, that's the end of their life. They're never going to be well. They're never going to be well-rounded or develop properly. Absolutely not. Like I said at the beginning, we're all about, like, a strength-based narrative on this show and the actions that we can take small and significant to overcome the difficulty, the difficulty. we are all going to experience at some stage in our lives. So I also want to talk about, firstly,
而且从长远来看，它可能真的、真的很具有危害性。我还想强调的是，如果这是你能感同身受的事情，这并不是某种死刑判决，就像你的人生证明上的一个标记，仿佛他们的人生就此结束了。他们永远不会健康。他们永远无法全面发展或正常成长。绝对不是。正如我在开头所说的那样，我们这个节目推崇的是基于力量的叙事，以及我们可以采取的小而有意义的行动，来克服我们在生命中的某个阶段都将经历的困难。所以我也想谈谈，首先，
some of the impacts and ways to identify the impacts that these parenting styles might have inflicted on us in the long term, but also the strategies and the mechanisms that we can adopt to kind of rise above the struggles and the harms that come along with toxic and narcissistic parenting styles. There has obviously been a lot of research into the impacts of toxic and narcissistic parenting and parents during our upbringing on the behaviours that we bring into adulthood. It's a huge part of social psychology to understand how our interpersonal relationships, including those that we have with our caregivers,
这些育儿方式在长期内可能对我们造成的某些影响以及识别这些影响的方法，还有我们可以采取的策略和机制，以便超越伴随有毒和自恋型育儿方式而来的挣扎与伤害。显而易见，关于有毒和自恋型育儿以及我们在成长过程中受到的有毒父母的影响，已经有很多研究，这些研究涉及我们带入成年期的行为。理解我们的人际关系（包括我们与照顾者的关系）如何，
ultimately kind of sets up our life trajectory in many ways. it can impact everything from the partners we choose to our career paths, our mental and emotional health in the company we keep. Studies have found that children of narcissistic parents have significantly higher rates of depression and lower self-esteem during adulthood compared to those who didn't perceive their parents or their caregivers to be narcissistic. Often a parent's lack of empathy towards their child contributes to this. You know, the child's own children. desires are denied. Their feelings are restrained, their emotional well-being is ignored for kind of the parents-perceived higher goal and higher desire to be perceived, for them to be perceived as well-liked,
最终在许多方面决定了我们的人生轨迹，这是社会心理学的重要组成部分。它会影响方方面面，从我们选择的伴侣到我们的职业生涯、我们的身心健康以及我们交往的朋友。研究发现，与那些没有觉得自己的父母或照顾者是自恋者的人相比，自恋型父母的孩子在成年后抑郁症的发病率明显更高，自尊心更低。父母对孩子缺乏同理心往往是造成这一现象的原因。你知道，孩子自己的愿望被否定了。他们的情感受到压抑，他们的情感福祉被忽视，为了父母心目中更高的目标和强烈的渴望——渴望被视为讨人喜欢的，
for them to be perceived as successful, often using their child as kind of a tool or a resource to get them there. Children of narcissistic parents, they're taught to submit, they're taught to conform, and it causes them to often lose touch of themselves as individuals and deny the parts of their individuality that they might value. And this can lead to the child possessing, in adulthood, often few memories of feeling appreciated or loved by their parents for being themselves because they tend to associate the love and appreciation they receive from their parents with conformity and with success.
渴望被视为成功的，他们往往把自己的孩子当成达到目的的工具或资源。自恋型父母的孩子被教导要顺从，被教导要循规蹈矩，这导致他们常常失去作为个体的自我，并否定他们可能珍视的个性部分。这可能导致孩子在成年后，几乎没有什么记忆能感受到父母因为他们是自己而对他们的欣赏或爱，因为他们倾向于将从父母那里得到的爱和欣赏与顺从和成功联系在一起。
You may also experience, you know, chronic stress if you've had toxic parents and other health problems because you're used to living in an environment in which you were neglected in which in which love was not a constant. It can also involve self-sabotaging if it's normal for you to be surrounded by toxic people because of the lessons and the habits you've picked up from your parents. You might struggle setting boundaries because, you know, if we think about the authoritarian, parent, like they always did that for you. We talked about this before, right? They set up this incredibly strict structure around you that you had to obey and follow. So when you're an adult, when you live on your own, when you go out and do your own thing, you no longer have that kind of, you no longer have that environment, that environment that's normal to you, that feels normal to you to go back to. So you've really struggled to set boundaries within your life because
如果你曾有过有毒的父母，你可能还会经历慢性压力和其他健康问题，因为你习惯生活在一种被忽视的环境中，在这种环境中爱不是恒久不变的。如果你因为从父母那里学到的教训和习惯，习惯了周围都是有毒的人，这还可能导致自我破坏。你可能会在设定界限时感到挣扎，因为，你知道，如果我们想到威权型父母，他们总是为你代劳。我们以前讨论过这个，对吧？他们在你周围建立了这种极其严格的结构，你必须服从和遵循。所以当你成年后，当你独自生活，当你走出去做自己的事情时，你不再拥有那种环境，那种对你来说正常、让你觉得正常的生活环境可以回去。所以你在生活中设定界限时真的会很挣扎，因为
someone else has always, you know, done that for you, has always done that in the past. I think people with dysfunctional relationships with their parents might also struggle with a lot of other things, right? They might struggle with trusting themselves, with their self-esteem, with their confidence. And studies have even suggested that our upbringing ultimately determines the people that we find attractive, the people that we inevitably date or form long-term partnerships with. important to remember that the first example of a romantic relationship and cohabitation that a children, that a child will often see is that of their parents or the couple that they live with. This is a really crucial way that our environment as a child and our parenting and
总有别人，你知道，为你代劳，过去一直是这样做的。我认为与父母关系失调的人可能也会在许多其他事情上挣扎，对吧？他们可能会在信任自己、自尊和自信方面挣扎。研究甚至表明，我们的成长经历最终决定了我们觉得有吸引力的人，以及我们不可避免地与之约会或建立长期伴侣关系的人。重要的是要记住，孩子通常看到的浪漫关系和同居的第一个榜样是他们的父母或他们与之生活在一起的伴侣。这是我们的儿童时期环境以及我们的育儿和
upbringing environment will have a major influence on some really important life decisions. What we see will affect what we expect from our own relationships. And it can influence our actions, you know, years down the line, ages into the future. Because our experiences in our upbringing, what we observe, what we expect, is going to influence how we perceive romantic love and choose a partner. So there are two theories around the impact of our parents on the partners we choose. The first is that we tend to choose partners and relationships that. that satisfies something we didn't have as a child, which sounds like a good thing, right? You know, when we're able to recognize, you know, like I didn't have security and consistency
成长环境将对一些真正重要的人生决策产生重大影响的一个极其关键的方式。我们所看到的将影响我们对自身关系的期望。它会影响我们的行为，你知道，多年以后，甚至未来的很长一段时间。因为我们在成长过程中的经历、我们所观察到的、我们所期望的，将影响我们如何看待浪漫爱情并选择伴侣。因此，关于父母对我们所选伴侣的影响，有两种理论。第一种是，我们倾向于选择能够满足我们在童年中未曾得到的东西的伴侣和关系，这听起来像是一件好事，对吧？你知道，当我们能够意识到，你知道，比如我没有安全感和持续性，
as a child because my parent was uninvolved or neglectful. We'll seek out a partner that treats us that way. But often when what sometimes psychologists and therapists see is when someone obtains that, it's really hard for them to let that go and they can become hyperdependent on that person because they've kind of given. them everything they never had. The other kind of theory is that we choose partners that mimic the relationships that we have with our caregivers. So if we had a narcissistic parent who we always had to impress, whose love was conditional on our successes and our accolades and the compliments and admiration we had for them, if we had parents who required a lot of praise and didn't have much
作为一个孩子，因为我的父母不参与或忽视我。我们会去寻找一个这样对待我们的伴侣。但通常情况下，心理学家和治疗师有时看到的是，当一个人得到了这个，他们很难放手，他们可能会对那个人产生过度依赖，因为那个人几乎给了他们所有他们从未拥有过的东西。另一种理论是，我们选择的伴侣模仿了我们与照顾者的关系。因此，如果我们有一个自恋的父母，我们总是必须去迎合他们，他们的爱取决于我们的成功、我们的荣誉以及我们对他们的赞美和崇拜，如果我们有父母需要大量的赞美并且对我们的感受没有太多
empathy for our feelings, this might be what we seek in a romantic partner. And the toxic relationship that we have with our parents evolves into a toxic romantic relationship in adulthood. Obviously, this is not always the case, and it also doesn't have to be the long-term impacts of toxic and narcissistic family and parenting environments can be mitigated and can be avoided. it. The parents we have are not the only determinants of the lives that we will lead. You know, the saying goes, it takes a village. And that definitely applies in this situation. The love we receive from other family members, like a grandparent or an aunt or an uncle, from our teachers, from our mentors, from our friends, their support, from our community,
同理心，这可能就是我们在浪漫伴侣中寻找的东西。我们与父母的有毒关系在成年后演变成了一种有毒的浪漫关系。很明显，情况并非总是如此，而且也不必如此——有毒和自恋的家庭及育儿环境带来的长期影响是可以减轻和避免的。我们拥有的父母并不是决定我们人生的唯一因素。你知道，有句俗话说，抚养一个孩子需要全村的努力。这在这种情况绝对适用。我们从其他家庭成员（如祖父母、阿姨或叔叔）、从我们的老师、从我们的导师、从我们的朋友那里得到的爱，来自他们支持，来自我们的社区，
the validation from activities beyond our families like school or sports or church if you attend. all of these can mitigate and protect us against the negative consequences of growing up with the toxic or narcissistic parent. And we also have a choice in many ways in determining the habits and the decisions that can bring us comfort and can allow us to heal. So I want to talk through some things that you can do if you've experienced this kind of upbringing or you've suffered through narcissistic parental abuse. to overcome this situation to kind of move past the experiences of your childhood. Firstly, it's important to mourn what you didn't have. Sometimes we actually need to sit in the grief and sit in the resentment and the emotion that we have for a little while before we can move forward.
来自学校、体育运动或你参加的教堂等家庭以外活动的肯定，所有这些都可以减轻并保护我们免受与有毒或自恋父母一起长大的负面影响。在很大程度上，我们也可以自主决定那些能带给我们安慰并让我们治愈的习惯和决策。所以我想探讨一些你可以做的事情，如果你经历过这种成长经历，或者遭受过自恋型父母虐待的话。如何克服这种状况，如何走出童年的经历。首先，重要的是哀悼你所失去的。有时我们实际上需要沉浸在悲伤中，沉浸在我们对父母的怨恨和情绪中一段时间，然后才能向前迈进。
If we don't take time in early adulthood to really recognize the feelings we have to our parents, the resentment, the blame, the guilt, even sometimes that we have. It just ends up being suppressed. And with suppression, there's a lack of recognition. You're not able to work on something or fix something that you can't acknowledge or understand yourself. So it is important to mourn what you didn't have. It's important to sit with the grief of the what ifs, the grief of the other possibilities. And hopefully kind of come to terms with the fact that this happened this was your experience but it doesn't mean that you can't live a really happy and quality life the other just essential essential feature of moving moving towards a healthy
如果我们没有在成年初期花时间真正去认识我们对父母的情感——那些怨恨、责怪，甚至有时存在的内疚感。它们最终只会遭到压抑。而伴随着压抑，就会缺乏认知。对于那些你无法承认或无法自己理解的事情，你是无法去改善或解决它的。所以，哀悼你所失去的是很重要的。直面那些“如果当初……”的悲伤，直面其他可能性的悲伤，这是很重要的。并且希望能够接受这样一个事实：这一切都发生了，这是你的经历，但这并不意味着你不能过上真正幸福且有品质的生活。另一个至关重要、不可或缺的特征是，走向与
relationship with a parent who may have treated you this way if that's something you want is to set boundaries you know you might benefit from some distance between you and a narcissistic or toxic parent you might want to ensure that you establish your non-negotiables. You know, if your parent is constantly picking on you or saying things that make you uncomfortable, you're an adult. You know, as part of it as it is, because of that controlling environment they may have built when you're a child. You don't have to put up with that. You don't have to depend on them anymore for their support. So set up non-negotiables, things that you won't tolerate from your family. You know, maybe you won't tolerate them
可能这样对待过你的父母建立健康关系（如果这是你想要的话）的方法，那就是设定界限。你知道，你可能会受益于与自恋或有毒父母保持一定距离，你可能希望确保确立你的不可妥协底线。你知道，如果你的父母不断挑剔你或说一些让你不舒服的话，你已经是成年人了。尽管由于他们在你小时候可能建立的那种控制型环境，这听起来有点不可思议。你没有必要忍受这些。你不再需要依靠他们的支持来生活。因此，请设定不可妥协的底线，设立那些你绝不容忍家人做出的行为。你知道，也许你不会容忍他们
showing up unexpectedly or visiting you or making unsolicited comments or judgments about your life choices. You can also ask that they don't have input into your life choices that, you know, sometimes there are these crossroads, right, where we can choose whether we want to borrow further into familial and parental control or forge our own path. Often a narcissistic parent might attempt to kind of keep us in their control and complying through financial support and financial assistance through gifts through manipulation and gaslighting. So do some of that work with a therapist or with a professional to identify what habits and what patterns of behavior your parent often does to get you back in, to bring you back
不请自来地出现、探望你，或者对你的人生选择发表不请自来的评论或评判。你也可以要求他们不要干涉你的人生选择，你知道，有时我们会面临这样的十字路口，对吧？我们可以选择是想更深地陷入家庭和父母的控制，还是开辟自己的道路。通常，自恋的父母可能会试图通过经济资助、经济援助、赠送礼物、操纵和煤气灯操纵（心理控制），来将我们保持在他们的控制之下并让我们顺从。因此，请与治疗师或专业人士合作，找出你的父母经常使用的哪些习惯和行为模式是为了把你拉回去，把你重新拉回
into the fold and write them down. Make sure you recognize them and you identify what it is about those behaviors that A makes you uncomfortable, that B is quite manipulative, and which C can be avoided, and which you can set up boundaries to prevent from happening because you do have to, essentially, and as hard as it is, take some kind of ownership to protect your own peace. The other thing we've talked about here that definitely needs addressing is the role of generational trauma that goes back decades and centuries and generations in kind of determining how a parent chooses to raise their child often doesn't even choose to raise their child.
他们的势力范围，并将它们写下来。确保你认出它们，并明确这些行为中：A，哪些让你感到不舒服；B，哪些具有相当大的操纵性；C，哪些是可以避免的，以及你可以通过设定界限来防止它们再次发生。因为你确实必须（尽管这很艰难）承担起某种责任来保护你内心的平静。我们在这里讨论过的另一件肯定需要解决的事情，是跨代创伤的作用。这种创伤可以追溯到几十年前、几百年前乃至好几代人，它决定了一个父母如何选择抚养孩子——通常甚至不是他们主动选择抚养孩子。
it's something that's unconscious, right? They don't necessarily choose to harm the children they bring into the world. They don't choose to be narcissistic. They don't choose to be neglectful or uninvolved. So sometimes we owe it to ourselves to, you know, work on ending the cycle of intergenerational trauma and intergenerational habits and learning, even if we don't plan on having kids ourselves.
这是一种无意识的东西，对吧？他们不一定选择去伤害带到这个世界上的孩子。他们不选择成为自恋者。他们不选择变得冷漠或不闻不问。所以有时我们亏欠自己去努力打破代际创伤、代际习惯和学习的循环，即使我们自己并不打算要孩子。
You know, the relationship we have with our caregivers, with our family, with our parents, impacts all other relationships, especially those we may have with our own kids. And if you don't have, you know, if you don't plan on having kids in the future, the people that we choose to nurture and bring into our lives. So I think it's important that once you've identified that this is a cycle that, you know, you've kind of been brought into, you somewhat have a duty to put a stop to it and to address the trauma
你知道，我们与照顾者、与家庭、与父母的关系，会影响所有其他关系，尤其是我们与自己孩子可能建立的关系。如果你没有，你知道，如果你未来不打算要孩子，它会影响我们选择去培育和带入我们生活的人。所以我认为，一旦你确定了这是一个你不知不觉被卷入其中的循环，你就有一种责任去制止它，去处理这些创伤，
and the significant things that have happened in your past, that your parents and your caregivers may not have had the bandwidth or the resources or the energy to deal with. I think it's important that if you've gone through this experience, if you can identify or relate to anything we've talked about today, you discuss the impact of that with people that you trust, people that love you, and you identify and relate to what your inner child,
以及过去发生的重大事情——你的父母和照顾者可能没有足够的精力、资源或能量来应对这些事情。我认为，如果你经历过这段经历，如果你能认同或共鸣我们今天讨论的任何内容，与你信任的人、爱你的人讨论这些影响，去认同和共鸣你内心的那个孩子——
your younger self, missed out on, or would have wanted from a parent and emulate that and how you treat the people you care about, how you treat the people that you nurture in your lives. Create an environment and create relationships that make you feel safe. You know, it's all about you now. You are allowed to be selfish and you're allowed to put yourself first, even if your parents and your family don't see it that way. And talk to a professional who can give you advice and address
那个年幼的自己——错过了什么，或者曾经希望从父母那里得到什么，并在你对待所关心的人的方式中、在你对待生活中你所培育的人的方式中去效仿它。创造一个让你感到安全的环境，建立让你感到安全的关系。你知道，现在一切都取决于你。你可以自私，你可以把你自己放在第一位，即使你的父母和家人并不这么认为。去和专业人士谈谈，他们可以给你建议并解决
any of the long-term psychological and emotional harms or insecurities that this upbringing may have caused. Finally, it might sound controversial, but it's important, I think, to forgive. Now, I know in instances of abuse, that is a lot easier said than done, and you don't always have to do that. You know, if this is not something for you, if you don't think you can forgive, if it's going to take too much mental energy, that is totally fine. You're allowed to be selfish and you're allowed to choose what you want to do with your life and make the decisions that are most appropriate for you. But I think, remember that you're not forgiving your parents or these people as a favour or an act of kindness to them or so that they can live their lives guilt-free. you're forgiving these people for yourself so that you can be released from a cycle of shame and trauma and move forward without as much resentment and emotional package.
这种成长经历可能造成的任何长期心理、情感伤害或不安全感。最后，这听起来可能有些争议，但我认为，原谅是很重要的。现在我知道，在遭受虐待的情况下，说起来容易做起来难，而且你并不总是必须这样做。你知道，如果这不适合你，如果你觉得无法原谅，如果这需要消耗太多的精神能量，那完全没问题。你可以自私，你可以选择你想如何度过你的一生，并做出最适合你的决定。但我认为，请记住，你原谅父母或这些人，不是作为对他们的某种恩惠或善意，也不是为了让他们能够毫无负罪感地生活。你原谅这些人是为了你自己，这样你就能从羞耻和创伤的循环中解脱出来，带着更少的怨恨和情感包袱继续前行。
So forgive, but don't forget. If you related to any of this today, I don't want to say I'm sorry because I don't want to, you know, make you feel like you're being pitied. But I do want to say you are incredibly strong and I'm proud of you for listening. to this episode and getting to know more about some of the psychology behind why are we if you know if you've had a narcissistic or a toxic parent why they may have acted this way why their behavior may have been this way and I think it's important knowledge and an important kind of understanding to bring into the holiday season as we feel pressure to see our families to reconnect to spend time with them and if you've gone through the process of establishing boundaries um
所以，选择原谅，但不要忘记。如果你今天对这些有所感触，我不想说我很抱歉，因为我不想让你觉得自己被同情。但我想说的是，你非常坚强，我为你收听这一集并更多地了解背后的心理学感到骄傲——为什么，如果你曾有过自恋或有毒的父母，他们为什么会这样行事，为什么他们的行为会是这样。我认为这是一项重要的知识，也是一种重要的理解，可以带入节假日季中，因为我们感受到探望家人、重新建立联系、花时间陪伴他们的压力，如果你已经完成了建立界限的过程，嗯，
for the right reasons and for reasons that you think are fair. Make sure you stick to them, right? Like these parents and these people, as we've described, have many ways of leveraging their role as our parent and their role as kind of the mature, superior person and the relationship to their advantage. So I think it's an important reminder around the holiday season that you're allowed to be selfish and do what's best for you
为了正确的理由，也为了你认为公平的理由。确保你坚持下去，对吧？就像我们所描述的那样，这些父母和这些人有很多方法可以利用他们作为我们父母的角色以及他们在关系中成熟、优越的地位来为自己谋利。所以我认为这是一个重要的提醒，在节日期间，你被允许自私一点，做对你最有利的事情，
if you've found yourself in this environment. I also want to say thank you so much for listening. If you're still here, if you're still with me, thank you for supporting the show. Thank you for listening to another episode. It was so great to have you along for the ride, to learn some more about this concept and experience and these feelings and realizations that we have in our 20s. If you feel called to do so, or if this episode benefited you in any way, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, wherever you're listening
如果你发现自己处于这种环境中。我也想非常感谢你的收听。如果你还在听，如果你还和我在一起，谢谢你支持这个节目。谢谢你收听又一集节目。很高兴你能加入这段旅程，了解更多关于这个概念、经历以及我们在二十多岁时拥有的这些感受和感悟。如果你愿意这样做，或者这一集在任何方面对你有所帮助，请随时在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts 或你目前收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。
right now. It really helps the show to grow and to reach new people. And thank you. Thank you again. I feel so blessed to have people who want to listen to this content and want to hear about these topics. I think they are so important and so fascinating. So thank you for coming on board for the ride. And I will see you next week for another episode of The Psychology of Your 20s. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalation. available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这真的对节目的成长和触达新受众有很大帮助。谢谢你们。再次谢谢你们。我感到非常幸运，能有这么多人想要聆听这些内容，想要了解这些话题。我认为它们非常重要且引人入胜。所以感谢你们加入这段旅程。我们下周将迎来《二十多岁心理学》的另一期节目。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇异的现代世界中培养心理坚韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down
收听《2%》。也就是在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方搜索“TWO percent”。在《回顾播客》节目中。对于1979年来说，那对我和我而言都是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
And try to make sense Of how we survived it With our friends Fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s It was a wild year
并试着理解我们是如何与朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家（如马丁·拉蒙特·希尔）一起熬过那段岁月的。谈到80年代，那真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think There's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio App Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Hey what's good
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。收听《回顾播客》，在 IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方。嘿，大家好，
y'all You're listening And learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
你们好。欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难一课》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲，
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcast 或任何你获取播客的地方收听《艰难一课》。这是一档 IHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可留下评论。